* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Es prasselte alles auf mich ein.
Es war klar,
dass ich vom Hof weggehen musste.
Es war so emotional.
Man denkt, all die Jahre
sein Bestes gegeben zu haben,
und dann hat man plötzlich
nichts mehr.
Frauen haben in der Schweiz
die gleichen Rechte wie Männer.
So steht es in der Verfassung.
* Kinderrufe *
(Frau) Ihr könnt auch draufspringen!
(Frau) Yeah! Super!
Die Realität sieht anders aus.
Danke vielmals!
Frauen erhalten weniger Lohn,
weniger Rente.
Ihre Arbeit wird geringgeschätzt
und viele von ihnen arbeiten gratis.
Diese Frauen haben im Alltag er-
fahren, wie hart das Leben sein kann.
* Sie ächzt. *
* Poltern *
Samuel ...
- Autsch!
Wir kommen bei der Garage heraus.
Doch Diskriminierung
und Frauenfeindlichkeit
akzeptieren sie nicht mehr.
Ich habe immer behauptet,
dass ich alles erreichen kann,
wenn ich fleissig arbeite
und vielleicht
mehr arbeiten muss als ein Mann.
Aber ich habe mir den Kopf an der
gläsernen Decke blutig geschlagen,
obwohl ich
alle Voraussetzungen hatte.
Wir haben 37 Jahre
Gleichstellungsartikel
und wir sind noch nirgends.
* Gläserne Klänge *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Spital Wallis. Abstellgleis
für Natalie Urwyler, 45 Jahre alt.
Ärztin
und ehemalige Wissenschaftlerin.
Sie haben keinen
peripheren Venenzugang mehr?
Nein, den hat man mir weggenommen.
- Ist das gut so?
Besten Dank!
Einen schönen Tag!
Adieu, Frau Doktor.
Natalie Urwyler hatte einst
eine glänzende Karriere vor sich.
Die ausgebildete Anästhesistin
arbeitete als Oberärztin
am Universitätsspital Bern.
* Vereinzelte, gezupfte Töne *
Sie war in der klinischen Forschung
tätig und auf dem Weg zur Professur.
Doch dann kam alles anders.
Mir wurde gekündigt.
Eigentlich auf der Spitze
meiner Karriere.
Ich hätte viel erreichen können.
Mir wurde missbräuchlich gekündigt.
Man hat eine Rachekündigung
ausgesprochen,
eigentlich der Höhepunkt
der Diskriminierung,
den man veranlassen kann.
Das ist schon sehr hart.
Ich habe alles verloren.
Ich habe alles verloren,
worauf ich mein ganzes Berufsleben
hingearbeitet habe.
Ich hatte nichts mehr,
ich stand mit nichts da.
Das Berner Inselspital: Anfang und
Ende von Natalie Urwylers Karriere.
Elf Jahre
hat die Ärztin hier gearbeitet,
hatte stets fachlich beste Zeugnisse,
generierte Forschungsgeld
und schaffte es in
einem hochkompetitiven Umfeld
an die ausländische Elite-Uni
Stanford.
Eigentlich ist es schon so:
Man macht seine Ausbildung,
wird Assistenzärztin, Oberärztin
und kommt irgendwann
in eine Führungsfunktion.
Ich habe nie infrage gestellt,
weshalb ich als Frau keine
Führungsfunktion übernehmen könnte.
Seit Jahren schliessen mehr Frauen
als Männer das Medizinstudium ab.
Es gibt mehr Assistenzärztinnen
als Assistenzärzte.
Doch mit steigender Hierarchie
verschwinden die Frauen.
Die Spitze an Schweizer Spitälern
ist männlich.
Auch Ärztin Urwyler
schaffte es nicht nach ganz oben.
Mit der Geburt ihres Kindes
war Schluss.
Ein Kind bedeutet heutzutage
offenbar wirklich immer noch
ein Bruch
in der Karriere einer Frau.
Das ist Ratlosigkeit,
echte Ratlosigkeit,
die da in einem hochkommt -
und Frustration.
* Diffuse Musik *
Sarah Schädeli, 47 Jahre alt.
Auch ihr Leben
nahm eine abrupte Wende.
Bis vor vier Jahren war sie Bäuerin.
Es war eine super Zeit auf dem Hof.
Ich hätte es eigentlich
nicht anders gewollt,
z.B., wie die Kinder
aufwachsen konnten und so.
Es ist eigentlich ...
Wir hatten wirklich
als Familie den Hof.
Weil es so gut war,
macht man sich keine Gedanken,
dass es auch mal
schlechter werden könnte.
Nach 17 Jahren
verliess Sarah Schädeli den Hof.
Sie hatte sich verliebt. In Jasmin.
Die Reaktionen auf die Liebe zu einer
Frau seien teils heftig gewesen,
sagt die ehemalige Bäuerin.
Richtig hart
traf sie aber etwas ganz anderes:
Für Bäuerinnen
gibt es nach der Scheidung
keine finanzielle Absicherung.
Obwohl in der Landwirtschaft -
wie anderswo in der Gesellschaft -
rund 40 % aller Ehen
in die Brüche gehen.
* Beschauliche Klänge,
zwitschernde Vögel *
Auf diesem Hof
hat Sarah Schädeli gelebt, gearbeitet
und drei Kinder grossgezogen.
Um die Familie zu unterstützen,
haben sich Sarah Schädelis Eltern
damals eine Wohnung
gleich nebenan gekauft.
Tochter Schädeli
kommt regelmässig hierher zu Besuch.
Happy Birthday!
Merci!
Alles Gute zum Geburtstag!
- Danke. Merci, Sarah. Danke.
Hallo!
Vater Heinz feiert Geburtstag.
* Sie reden
und lachen durcheinander. *
Die Familie trifft sich häufig.
Für die Kinder von Sarah Schädeli
sind die Grosseltern wichtig.
Sie sind eine Art Bindeglied
zur Mutter.
Nach der Trennung
blieben die Kinder auf dem Hof.
Es hat mich auch immer
relativ viel Kraft gekostet -
das ganze Emotionale.
Schauen,
dass man den Kindern gerecht wird.
Es war mir wichtig,
dass es auch ihnen gut geht dabei.
Und dann sollte man sich
noch um das Rechtliche kümmern,
wo man selbst eigentlich ... ja ...
nicht wirklich eine Ahnung hat.
Ich bin davon ausgegangen:
Man hat gemeinsam etwas erschaffen.
Ich habe auch viel Arbeit geleistet.
Wir konnten den Hof
so weiterbringen.
Es war für mich klar,
dass das aufgeteilt wird.
Die Landwirtschaft tickt anders.
Bei einer Scheidung wird der Hof,
also das Kapital und die eigentliche
Vorsorge der Bauern, nicht geteilt.
So will es das bäuerliche Bodenrecht.
Meist gehört der Hof dem Mann.
So auch bei Sarah Schädeli.
Eine obligatorische Absicherung
für die Frau gibt es nicht.
Die Eltern von Sarah Schädeli
haben die Trennung hautnah miterlebt.
(Mutter) Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich im Keller war.
Als ich aus dem Keller kam,
war sie da: aufgelöst.
In Tränen aufgelöst.
Sie sagte, sie habe nichts zugute.
Das war schon ein Schock!
"Ich bekomme nichts!"
Als ich das mitbekommen habe,
dass eine Frau,
die 16 Jahre dort drüben war,
nichts, aber wirklich
gar nichts zugute hat ...
Äh ...
Das ist ...
Ich konnte es kaum glauben,
aber es war effektiv so.
Es war so emotional.
Man denkt, dass man all die Jahre
sein Bestes gegeben hat.
Und plötzlich hat man nichts mehr.
Ich kann es gar nicht so ...
Ich kann es nicht fassen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Vor fünf Jahren stand
die Narkoseärztin Natalie Urwyler
beruflich vor dem Nichts, kurz
nach der Geburt von Tochter Nina.
Urwyler wollte Karriere
und Mutterschaft verbinden.
Ich habe sehr lange damit gewartet,
ein Kind zu bekommen.
Es kam immer wieder die Frage
der Vorgesetzten oder die Auflage:
Kind oder Karriere.
Ich hatte auch grosse Ängste,
dass es nicht geht,
weil ich merkte,
dass man mir die Schraube zudrehte.
Mutterschutz und Gleichberechtigung -
dafür hatte sich Urwyler bei ihrem
Arbeitgeber, dem Berner Inselspital,
schon immer eingesetzt.
Selbst davon betroffen,
kommt es zur Eskalation:
Urwyler akzeptiert die Bedingungen
für den Wiedereinstieg
nach dem Mutterschaftsurlaub nicht.
Nach der Geburt meines Kindes
erlaubte man mir keine
wissenschaftliche Tätigkeit mehr.
Meine sämtlichen Forschungsgelder
wurden gesperrt.
Ich hatte
keinen Zugriff mehr darauf.
Der Studentenunterricht wurde
annulliert - der war fix zugesagt.
Für mich ging grundsätzlich
die Haltung nicht,
dass ich als Mutter
nicht mehr forschen kann.
Das war Sinn und Zweck
meines Auslandaufenthaltes,
des Nationalfondstipendiums,
das ich hatte
und von dem ich
aus dem Ausland zurückkam.
Das hat alles
in die Richtung gearbeitet.
Das Inselspital bestreitet die
Darstellung, doch Urwyler wehrt sich:
Sie beschwert sich bei
der internen Gleichstellungsbehörde
von Spital und Universität:
"Wegen Diskriminierung und Verhin-
derung der akademischen Karriere".
Kurz darauf erhält sie die Kündigung.
Begründung:
"Das Arbeitsverhältnis
zwischen Ihnen und dem Inselspital
ist aufgrund zahlreicher Vorfälle
über längere Zeit hinweg
sehr belastet worden."
Das Vertrauensverhältnis
sei nachhaltig gestört.
Ich konnte es nicht glauben.
Ich dachte wirklich:
Es kann nicht sein,
was mir hier passiert.
Was dann passiert,
sorgt schweizweit für Schlagzeilen:
Die Ärztin verklagt den grössten
Spitalkonzern der Schweiz
wegen Diskriminierung und Verletzung
des Gleichstellungsgesetzes.
Ich habe mich für meine Rechte
gewehrt, aber ich habe diese Rechte.
Ich habe sie
aufgrund der Schweizer Verfassung.
Ich habe sie aufgrund
des Reglements, welches sich
das Inselspital und die Universität
Bern selbst auferlegt haben.
Ich habe diese Rechte
auch aufgrund der Gesetze,
die wir in der Schweiz
für den Mutterschutz haben.
Ich habe keine
überrissene Forderung gestellt.
Ich habe nur das eingefordert, was
man mir jahrelang vorgesungen hat,
was Frauen heute alles
können, sollen, dürfen und tun.
Mehr habe ich nicht gemacht. Aber:
Für die grauen Eminenzen
war das schon sehr schwierig,
dass nun mal eine Frau nicht sagt:
"Jawohl, ich mache das."
Sondern: "Hey, wir haben ein
Reglement, wir haben ein Gesetz."
"Würden Sie dem bitte
Folge leisten!"
Pause wieder.
Edith Tanner mit ihrem Sohn Samuel.
* Brüllen *
Jetzt ist gut. Das ist etwas heftig.
* Samuel lacht brüllend. *
Seit 18 Jahren pflegt und betreut
die Mutter ihren behinderten Sohn -
unentgeltlich.
Samuel
ist das jüngste von drei Kindern.
Von Geburt an war er anders
als seine beiden älteren Schwestern.
Was er hat, bleibt lange unklar.
Es waren Wahnsinnsjahre.
Samuel hat die ersten
dreieinhalb Jahre nicht geschlafen.
Das war für mich das Strengste
an seiner Behinderung.
Das maximal Strengste!
Nicht, weil er nicht schlief,
sondern weil er schrie.
Er hatte Alarm in der Nacht.
Er hatte Angst in der Nacht.
Und das war sehr anstrengend.
Als Samuel sechs Jahre alt ist,
wird bei ihm eine
Wahrnehmungsstörung diagnostiziert.
Seine Entwicklung ist verlangsamt.
Bei kleinsten Dingen braucht er
immer wieder Unterstützung.
Schneidest du?
Oh-oh.
- Ist es hart?
Soll ich helfen?
- Nein.
Wie sollen wir es machen?
Ich soll schneiden?
Schau, wir versuchen es so.
* Schneidgeräusch *
Samuels taktile und intermodale
Wahrnehmungsstörung
ist vergleichbar
mit dem Verhalten eines Autisten.
Er ist rund um die Uhr
auf Betreuung und Pflege angewiesen.
Die Hauptverantwortung für Samuel
hatte immer Mutter Edith.
Von Samuels Vater lebte sie getrennt,
inzwischen ist er gestorben.
Sie musste stets auswärts arbeiten.
Vor sechs Jahren hatte Edith Tanner
einen Erschöpfungszusammenbruch.
Ich wusste,
dass ich diesen Riesenballast
von 300 % Einsatz -
und das ist nicht übertrieben -
loswerden musste.
Das ging aber nicht.
Es war eine lange Suche.
Wie bringe ich
meine Verantwortung Samuel gegenüber
und die Verantwortung mir und meinen
Kräften gegenüber unter einen Hut?
Menschen mit einer Beeinträchtigung
wie Samuel haben das Recht,
stationär - in einem Heim - oder
ambulant bei sich zu Hause zu wohnen.
Für Mutter Edith
kam das Heim nicht infrage.
Sie fand
keine angemessene Institution.
Mir geht es nicht darum, dass ich
Samuel bei mir behalten will.
Das ist einer der Hauptvorwürfe,
man könne das Kind nicht loslassen.
Und blablablabla.
Das ist überhaupt nicht so.
Man kann das Kind loslassen,
wenn es laufen kann.
Das ist bei jedem Kind so.
Gäbe es eine Institution,
wo Samuel laufen lernen könnte -
im übertragenen Sinn -, dürfte er
sofort dorthin. Das ist nicht ...
Ich bin nicht die Einzige,
die weiss, was er braucht.
Weil Samuel nicht im Heim ist,
muss Mutter Edith übernehmen.
Sie gehört damit zu rund
300'000 pflegenden Angehörigen
in der Schweiz,
die eines verbindet:
Sie leisten unendlich viel Arbeit -
gratis.
Auf ihre Kosten
spart der Staat Milliarden.
Die Mehrheit der
pflegenden Angehörigen sind Frauen.
Für betreuungs- und pflegebedürftige
Menschen wie Samuel
funktioniert die Versorgung
ausserhalb des Heims
in vielen Kantonen nicht lückenlos.
Angehörige springen ein.
Ohne Menschen wie Edith Tanner
würde das Sozialsystem kollabieren.
Der Staat rechnet
mit ihrer unbezahlten Arbeit.
Doch Edith Tanner will nicht mehr.
Das Ziel ist eigentlich,
dass Samuel, was auch immer,
wer auch immer ihn begleitet,
seine Hilfen bezahlen kann.
Dann kann ich
meinen Gratismutterjob auflösen.
Es ist nicht richtig.
Es ist nicht richtig, dass eine
Mutter eines volljährigen Menschen
immer noch so viele Stunden pro Tag
verpflichtet ist.
Frauen leisten hierzulande
Unmengen an Gratisarbeit.
Ein exemplarisches Beispiel dafür
ist die Landwirtschaft:
17 Jahre hat Bäuerin Schädeli
auf einem Hof gearbeitet.
Nach der Trennung
stand sie vor dem Nichts.
Gerade junge Frauen, die ...
... die z.T. wirklich so ...
... die wie ich vielleicht geblendet
sind von der Idylle, dem Schönen,
dem "Man hat es gut miteinander" ...
Man muss auch an den Punkt denken,
dass etwas passieren kann.
Es muss nicht immer eine Trennung
oder Scheidung sein.
Es kann auch Invalidität
oder was auch immer sein.
Dann sollte die Frau, die viel
geleistet hat, abgesichert sein.
Sind sie aber oft nicht.
Zwei Drittel der Frauen in
der Landwirtschaft haben keinen Lohn.
D.h. weder Mutterschaftsversicherung
noch sonstige
finanzielle Absicherung.
Sarah Schädeli geht zur ehemaligen
Präsidentin der Schweizer Bäuerinnen.
Mit ihr will sie
den Missstand bekämpfen.
Zu Beginn des Jahres
kam die Diskussion auf,
dass sich die Bauern und der Bauern-
verband wirklich dagegenstellen,
Sozialversicherungen für ihre Bäuer-
innen, für ihre Frauen zu machen.
Dass sie das einfach, ich sage mal,
eiskalt ablehnen und sagen:
"Nein, wir brauchen das nicht,
das wollen wir nicht."
"Die Landwirte
können sonst nicht existieren,
und es gibt einen zusätzlichen
administrativen Aufwand."
Das finde ich ziemlich daneben,
auf Berndeutsch gesagt.
Christine Bühler, bis vor Kurzem
oberste Bäuerin der Schweiz,
macht seit Jahren Druck.
Sie will einen Lohn für Bäuerinnen
und eine soziale Absicherung.
Doch die Bauernschaft ist gespalten,
betroffene Frauen
äussern sich häufig nur anonym.
Bühler braucht Frauen wie Schädeli,
um das Problem sichtbar zu machen.
Ich suche eigentlich
die Öffentlichkeit nicht.
Aber ich möchte anderen Frauen
wirklich auch Mut machen.
Meine Geschichte
ist eine von vielen.
Und jede
ist irgendwie unterschiedlich.
Sagt man, es sei gut, wie es ist,
dann ist es auch gut.
Aber es braucht
eine gesetzliche Verankerung.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck,
die Bauern haben das Gefühl,
man will ihnen etwas wegnehmen.
Dieses Etwas
ist vielleicht die Macht.
Mhm.
- So sehe ich es.
Oder einfach,
dass sie nicht mehr verfügen können.
Und ...
Wir wissen einfach,
dass das heutzutage
nicht mehr zeitgemäss ist.
Entfernt sich der Bauernstand
so von der Gesellschaft,
ist das ganz schlecht.
Bühler sagt, in der Landwirtschaft
von "Ein-Mann-Betrieben" zu reden,
sei realitätsfremd
und frauenfeindlich.
Die Arbeit von Frau und Mann
in der Landwirtschaft
müsse gleich viel wert sein.
Die Sklaverei wurde abgeschafft.
Das ist wirklich ...
Die Frauen leisten eine Arbeit,
die sich im Betriebsertrag
niederschlägt.
Sie können auch nicht jemanden
einstellen und einfach sagen:
"Du hast Kost und Logis
und noch eine Krankenkasse -
jetzt sei zufrieden!"
Das geht nicht.
Das finde ich so schlimm.
Und dort, wo es am Nötigsten ist,
wo das Einkommen etwas knapp ist,
wo die Beziehung vielleicht auch
schon ein paar Sprünge hat ...
... ähm ...
... dort braucht es Druck,
damit das angewendet wird.
Gleichberechtigung
in der Landwirtschaft -
ein konkreter Vorschlag
liegt nun auf dem Tisch:
Der Bundesrat
will eine obligatorische,
minimale soziale Absicherung
für Bäuerinnen im Gesetz verankern.
Das Parlament
wird darüber entscheiden.
* Unverständliche Worte *
Edith Tanner und ihr Sohn Samuel.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
Du brauchst noch Unterhosen
und Socken.
Die Mutter will erreichen,
dass der 18-Jährige
selbstbestimmt in seinen
eigenen vier Wänden leben kann -
ohne ihre Gratishilfe.
Jesses!
- Die Unterhosen.
* Er räuspert sich. *
Die brauche ich.
- Das ist gut.
* Unverständliche Worte *
Sind Wollsocken nicht zu heiss?
Kein einfacher Weg.
Rechtlich, aber auch moralisch.
Sie habe immer wieder
zu hören bekommen,
eine Mutter mache das doch einfach.
Edith Tanner hat sich Unterstützung
geholt bei einem Anwalt in Glarus.
Hardy Landolt, Professor
für Sozialversicherungsrecht
und Tetraplegiker
seit dem 14. Lebensjahr.
Hardy Landolt ist spezialisiert
auf die komplexe Thematik
von pflegenden Angehörigen
und betreut viele ähnliche Fälle
wie den von Edith Tanner.
Ohne seine Hilfe
hätte ich schon lange aufgegeben.
Ohne eine Rechtshilfe in der Art,
wie er sie gibt,
hätte ich aufgeben müssen,
es wäre gar nicht gegangen.
Als Angehörige
wird man nicht ernst genommen.
Es braucht das Zwischenstück eines
Juristen, einer juristischen Person,
um sich überhaupt Gehör verschaffen
zu können. Das ist leider so.
Edith Tanners Problem:
Die IV bezahlt zwar Assistenzbeiträge
und Hilflosenentschädigung
für die Betreuung ihres Sohnes,
allerdings zu wenig, damit er
unabhängig von ihr leben kann.
Und: Die Spitex im Kanton kann die
Pflege von Samuel nicht übernehmen.
Für Anwalt Landolt inakzeptabel,
dass Angehörige wie Edith Tanner
solch staatliche Versorgungslücken
decken müssen.
Man muss nicht jede innerfamiliäre
Handreichung vergolden.
Aber versicherte Leistungen,
für die man Prämien bezahlt,
nicht mit geeigneten Ver-
sorgungsstrukturen aufzufangen ...
Das ist, wie wenn Sie
für den Arztbesuch versichert sind
und irgendein Kanton würde sagen,
es würde in dem Kanton
keine Hausärzte geben.
Sie sind versichert,
Sie haben einen Anspruch darauf,
dass die Kosten übernommen werden.
Nun erbringt der Staat
aber die Leistungen nicht.
In dem Bereich
wird natürlich brutal Geld gespart.
Das ist total fehl am Platz.
Total, ähm ...
Es ist eine Fehlentwicklung,
bei der tatenlos zugeschaut wird.
Man hat ja die Frauen -
mehrheitlich Frauen -,
die unentgeltlich
diese Leistungen erbringen.
Hardy Landolt weiss,
wovon er spricht:
Auch sein eigener ambulanter Bedarf
war nicht gedeckt.
Seine Frau sprang ein.
Doch Christel Kalunder
pflegt ihn nicht mehr gratis.
Die ausgebildete Pflegefachfrau
rechnet über ihre eigene Firma ab.
Für die Akzeptanz
dieses innerfamiliären Modells
mussten sie
bis vor Bundesgericht gehen.
Die beiden
gingen noch einen Schritt weiter:
Sie gründeten eine private Spitex,
um Angehörige ohne Pflegeausbildung
anzustellen.
Mittlerweile arbeiten
bei der Fridli-Spitex 15 Angehörige.
Die Firma rechnet jetzt ihre Arbeit
über die Krankenkasse ab.
Auf diese Weise erhält
die Pflegearbeit der Angehörigen
einen monetären Wert.
Das war ein Freudentag!
Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass Angehörige über Jahre,
vielleicht sogar Jahrzehnte, erst-
mals eine Lohnabrechnung erhalten
oder erhalten haben.
Als mein Mann und ich
den ersten Lohn überwiesen hatten,
gab es aus Freude Champagner.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, ob es Champag-
ner war, aber wir haben gefeiert.
Wir stellten uns vor,
wie das bei den Eltern ankommt,
die Kinder pflegen,
oder bei einem Angehörigen,
der seinen Partner pflegt.
Sie haben es einfach auch verdient.
Ganz einfach ging das nicht:
Edith Tanner musste
vor das kantonale Verwaltungsgericht,
damit ihr Anspruch auf Pflegelohn
anerkannt wurde.
* Sanfte Musik,
unverständliche Worte von Samuel *
Heute erhält sie von der
Fridli-Spitex 1'200 Fr. pro Monat -
ein Teilerfolg.
Sie pflegt und betreut ihren Sohn
noch immer
rund 7 Std. pro Tag gratis.
Die entsprechenden Klagen
sind hängig.
* Kinderstimmen *
Es gibt eine Geringschätzung der
Arbeit, sobald sie Frauen machen.
Das bestätigen Studien.
Diese jungen Frauen wissen,
was das im Alltag heisst:
Rebecca Lüthi und Camilla Carboni
sind Fachpersonen Kinderbetreuung,
sog. FaBeK.
Sie arbeiten in Kitas.
Wir haben schon Inserate gelesen:
"Kita sucht liebevolle Frau ..."
- Ja.
Oder irgendwie:
"... die gut mit Kindern kann."
Ja , genau.
- Also ganz plump.
Man muss einfach können.
Was immer auch können heisst.
Das ist für uns
wie eine Faust ins Gesicht.
Wir haben
eine dreijährige Ausbildung gemacht
und verfügen über
pädagogisches Hintergrundwissen.
Dann ärgert man sich schon.
Es gibt viele solche Situationen.
Ich sitze abends müde im Zug
und werde gefragt:
"Wieso bist du müde?
Du arbeitest ja mit Kindern."
"Ihr schaut Büchlein an
und singt den ganzen Tag."
Dann denkt man:
"Hey, komm einen Tag in die Kita -
dann rede ich gerne
noch einmal mit dir."
* Beschwingte Musik *
Bereit?
- (Alle) Ja!
(Laut) Bereit?
- (Alle, laut) Ja!
Yeah!
Anstatt zu jammern über mangelnde
Wertschätzung, haben sie gehandelt:
Vor zwei Jahren gründeten
Kita-Mitarbeiterinnen aus Zürich
die Trotzphase.
Die Gruppe will die prekären Arbeits-
bedingungen der Kita-Branche benennen
und geht dafür auf die Strasse.
Sie bereiten Transparente
für ihren nächsten Termin vor:
den Frauenstreiktag.
"Fertig mit der Bescheidenheit,
Erzieherinnen
sind jetzt streikbereit!"
Mit Kindern zu arbeiten,
war Camilla Carbonis Traumjob.
Sie arbeitet nur noch
als Aushilfe in Kitas.
Zu stressig, zu unbefriedigend
die Arbeitsbedingungen.
Wir dürfen Camilla Carboni
während 2 Std.
in einer städtischen Kita
mitten in Zürich filmen.
Während dieser Zeit
läuft alles wie im Bilderbuch ab.
Die Arbeit ist sehr dankbar.
Die Kinder
geben einem sehr viel zurück.
So wie gerade jetzt diese Situation.
Es ist sehr schön.
Tatsache ist leider, dass es
ganz häufig nicht so ist wie jetzt,
sondern dass man z.B.
mit sieben Kindern alleine ist.
Alle Grundbedürfnisse müssen
gleichzeitig gedeckt werden,
damit die Kinder
für den Moment versorgt sind.
Eine solche Interaktion wie im
Moment kommt leider viel zu kurz.
Und es ist ...
Leider ist es ganz häufig so,
dass es einfach ein Herumrennen ist.
Man kann nicht so arbeiten,
wie man es gelernt hat
und wie man es gerne möchte.
Abends ist man enttäuscht,
weil man den Kindern
nicht so gerecht werden konnte.
Zu viele Kinder, zu wenig Personal.
Eine repräsentative Umfrage der Stadt
Zürich aus dem Jahr 2014
bestätigt diese Kritik.
In Deutschschweizer Kitas
gibt es keinen Gesamtarbeitsvertrag,
vielerorts gelten nur minimale
Bestimmungen des Arbeitsgesetzes.
Praktikantinnen werden als
vollwertige Arbeitskräfte eingesetzt.
Auch der Lohn
ist für die Angestellten minimal.
Es gibt keine verbindlichen Vorgaben.
Der Verband Kibesuisse empfiehlt
nach der dreijährigen Ausbildung
4'000 bis 4'200 Fr. Einstiegslohn.
Mit Berufserfahrung
steigt er nur marginal an.
Der Lohn wäre eine Möglichkeit,
um uns Wertschätzung
entgegenzubringen.
Wenn er so tief ist, ist es
ein zusätzlicher Punkt. um zu sagen:
"Hey, das mache ich so
nicht mehr mit -
unter diesen Arbeitsbedingungen."
Wäre der Lohn etwas höher, würde man
vielleicht noch länger durchhalten,
weil man angemessen entlöhnt wird.
Aber wenn das auch nicht stimmt,
dann ...
Und ich glaube ...
Die Sache ist ...
Bis vor Kurzem, sage ich mal,
sind viele Mütter zu Hause geblieben
und haben ihre Kinder betreut,
gratis.
Zum Glück hat es sich verändert.
Es gibt heute Kitas,
und Mütter können arbeiten gehen.
Es hat sich nun aber verlagert.
Nun arbeiten viele Frauen in Kitas
zu einem sehr tiefen Lohn
und unter schlechten
Arbeitsbedingungen.
Man muss darauf aufmerksam machen:
Wir leisten eine wichtige Arbeit.
Die Kinder müssen und sollen
in der Gesellschaft funktionieren.
Und es geht um die ersten fünf Jahre
von diesen Kindern.
Und, ähm ...
Die Wertschätzung,
die fehlende Wertschätzung
zeigt sich auch im tiefen Lohn.
Die jungen Frauen sind mit
dem Selbstverständnis aufgewachsen:
Für Frauen und Männer
gelten die gleichen Rechte.
Sind Sie eine Putzfrau?
(Lachend) Manchmal schon, ja.
(Rebecca) Wir zeigen alles,
was wir können.
(Mann) Genau.
Die Frauen kann man brauchen.
Ihr Job hat sie gelehrt:
Die Abwertung ihres typischen
Frauenberufs findet täglich statt.
Für die externe Familienbetreuung
braucht man sie zwar dringend,
doch am liebsten möglichst günstig.
Mehr Lohn, mehr Personal und
keine billigen Praktikantinnen mehr.
Mit Unterstützung der Gewerkschaft
VPOD sammelt die Trotzphase
Unterschriften für bessere Arbeits-
bedingungen von Kita-Angestellten:
Wir wollen einen GAV, der festlegt,
wie viele Leute in der Krippe mit
wie vielen Kindern arbeiten dürfen.
Das muss festgelegt sein
und nicht nach Gutdünken geschehen,
auch wenn es Richtlinien gibt,
an denen man sich orientieren kann.
Dafür sammeln wir jetzt
diese Unterschriften.
* Lockere Musik *
Dass es dauern kann,
bis ein Gesamtarbeitsvertrag steht,
darauf stellen sich die Frauen ein,
denn dass man in Sachen Gleich-
stellung einen langen Atem braucht,
zeigt das Beispiel
von Natalie Urwyler.
Sie war Anästhesieärztin
am Inselspital in Bern.
Vor fünf Jahren strengte sie
einen Gerichtsprozess an,
der Aufsehen erregte.
Mir wurde gekündigt. Damit hätte ich
grundsätzlich noch umgehen können.
Aber als ich feststellte,
dass man hinter meinem Rücken
gegen mich lobbyierte und
in anderen Spitälern dafür sorgte,
dass ich keine Stelle auf
einer anderen Anästhesie mehr bekam,
brachte das das Fass zum Überlaufen.
Man sagte mir das
an einem Bewerbungsgespräch auch.
Da fasste ich den Entschluss:
"Jetzt reicht's."
"Jetzt hat das Fass überlaufen.
Die Männer sind zu weit gegangen."
"Jetzt gehe ich vor Gericht."
Ende 2014 klagte die Narkoseärztin
gemeinsam mit ihrem Anwalt
gegen den grössten Spitalkonzern
der Schweiz - wegen Rachekündigung -
aufgrund des Gleichstellungsgesetzes.
Er hat mir gesagt, was man
für einen solchen Prozess braucht.
Wir haben uns auch angesehen,
wie man die Beweisführung
beim Gleichstellungsgesetz macht.
Ich habe mich auch
von der Berner kantonalen Stelle
für Gleichstellung beraten lassen.
Danach musste ich erst mal sehr,
sehr viel Zeit investieren,
die Sachen wirklich raussuchen.
Ich wusste ... Ich als Forscherin
bin natürlich eine Sammlerin
und werfe eigentlich selten
etwas weg.
Ich habe dann meinen Computer,
die elektronische Datenbank,
meine Post, meine Briefe,
meine Mitarbeitergespräche usw.
durchsucht.
Der höchste Beweis
ist der Urkundenbeweis.
Der Prozess muss
auf dem Geschriebenen aufbauen,
nicht auf Aussagen.
Das Inselspital bestritt
vor Gericht die Rachekündigung.
Schuld sei Urwyler selbst
mit ihrem Verhalten.
Sie sei illoyal, nicht teamfähig,
dominant und überschätze sich.
Das Vertrauensverhältnis sei gestört,
darum die Kündigung.
Doch Urwylers Dokumente
hielten stand.
Das Inselspital konnte den Vorwurf
des gestörten Vertrauensverhältnisses
nicht beweisen.
Natalie Urwyler erhielt 2018
vor dem Obergericht des Kantons Bern
auch zweitinstanzlich recht.
Das Inselspital
hatte der Ärztin aus Rache gekündigt,
weil sie intern
Diskriminierung angeprangert hatte
und diese Beschwerde hängig war.
Das Urteil ist wegweisend.
Es geht um einen Verfassungsauftrag:
Gleichbehandlung von Mann und Frau.
Den muss man umsetzen.
Er wurde in diesem Fall
nicht umgesetzt
und wird in vielen anderen Fällen
auch nicht umgesetzt.
Das finde ich als Jurist
höchst bedenklich.
Man hat einen Verfassungsauftrag.
Das Frauenstimmrecht
wurde 1971 eingeführt,
und seither hat sich von
der Mentalität her wenig geändert.
Die sozialromantischen Szenarien
aus dem 17., 18. Jh. -
Mann Jäger, Frau Sammlerin -
wirken immer noch nach und sind die
Grundlage für die Männerkulturen,
die letzten Endes
so unerträglich sind.
Das ist eine permanente
Verletzung des Verfassungsrechts,
und das interessiert
mich als Jurist natürlich.
Für mich selbst ist dieses Urteil
eigentlich schon Gerechtigkeit.
Es zeigt, was das
Gleichstellungsgesetz besagt,
und das Gericht
verurteilt auch einen Betrieb
wegen einer Rachekündigung.
Für mich ist das Problem,
dass es für mich persönlich
nicht wirklich
grosse Konsequenzen hat,
denn ich wurde
sofort wieder freigestellt.
Ich darf trotzdem nicht arbeiten,
ich darf trotzdem nicht weiter
Wissenschaft betreiben.
Meine Karriere
ist genauso ruiniert wie vorher.
Darum ist es für mich selbst ...
Auf dem Papier ist es Gerechtigkeit,
aber im wahren Leben
hat es mir nichts gebracht.
Ich hoffe aber, dass es
vielen anderen Frauen künftig hilft.
Natalie Urwyler tat,
was viele Frauen nicht wagen:
Anklage erheben gegen
einen übermächtigen Arbeitgeber
und Gleichstellung einfordern.
Ich kann sehr gut nachvollziehen,
wenn sich Frauen nicht antun wollen,
was ich mit dem Prozess getan habe.
Es braucht
unheimlich viel Energie und Kraft.
Die Unterstützung von Familie und
Freunden sei damals zentral gewesen.
Allen voran die ihres Partners,
des Arztes Bruno Kämpfen.
Er hat mich sehr unterstützt
und ermutigt und mir auch gesagt,
dass nicht sein könne,
was da passiere.
So könne man
mit Frauen nicht umgehen.
Ohne ihn
hätte ich das nicht gemacht.
Allein wäre ich in der Phase gleich
nach der Kündigung zerbrochen.
Ich sagte: "Wir ziehen das durch,
koste es, was es wolle."
"Auch wenn wir
die Wohnung verkaufen müssen."
"Das wird investiert."
"Es kann nicht grenzenlos gehen,
aber das wird gemacht."
Es geht nicht,
dass hier in der Schweiz
gewisse Leute das Recht so verändern
und nicht einhalten.
Wir müssen uns wehren.
Wo Unrecht zu Recht wird,
wird Widerstand zur Pflicht.
Die Klage hatte für Urwyler
knallharte Konsequenzen:
Während des laufenden Verfahrens
fand sie keine Anstellung
in der Anästhesie.
Die habilitierte Narkoseärztin
fand schliesslich einen Job
am Spital Wallis
als Assistenzärztin
auf einem anderen Fachgebiet.
Dominique Evequoz,
Chefarzt am Spital,
war damals mitverantwortlich
für ihre Anstellung.
Dass gegen Urwyler lobbyiert wurde,
bestätigt er indirekt.
Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts
sagte ein Walliser Politiker
namens Maurice Troillet -
er war etwa 50 Jahre Regierungsrat -
wenn ein Befehl von Bern komme,
müsse er
den ganzen Weg auf die Alpen gehen -
den Berg hoch und wieder runter.
Danach seien die Befehle
viel weniger prägnant
und hätten ihre Macht verloren.
Das habe ich immer im Kopf behalten.
Und ich sagte:
"Nein, so geht das nicht."
Ich sagte: "Diese Person nehmen wir,
die müssen wir einstellen,
egal, was passiert ist."
"Wir kennen sie.
Sie hat eine sehr gute Ausbildung."
"Eine Person, die sich einsetzt,
darf man nicht
auf die Strasse werfen."
"Sie muss eine Chance haben."
Die haben wir ihr gegeben
und es nie bereut.
Das Inselspital bestreitet, je gegen
Natalie Urwyler lobbyiert zu haben.
Das Spital
schreibt in einer Stellungnahme,
die Aussage von Chefarzt Evequoz
könne man "nicht nachvollziehen".
Auf Jobsuche war vor vier Jahren auch
die ehemalige Bäuerin Sarah Schädeli.
Nach der Trennung
und dem Weggang vom Hof,
war die berufliche Zukunft ungewiss.
Nach drei Monaten
blieben mir noch 2'500 Fr.
Ich wusste,
ich brauchte eine Stelle,
sonst würde quasi
meine Existenz zugrunde gehen,
bzw. müsste ich
aufs Sozialamt gehen.
Ich musste mich wieder dem
normalen Bewerbungsprozess stellen.
Ich habe mich quasi wieder
auf dem freien Markt beworben,
um kaufmännische Stellen,
also in meinem angestammten Bereich.
Ich wäre gerne in die
Versicherungsbranche zurückgegangen.
Ich habe bei verschiedenen
Versicherungsbrokern gearbeitet.
Dort hat mir
das Ganzheitliche gefallen.
Letzten Endes war ich froh,
überhaupt wieder
etwas gefunden zu haben.
Heute ist sie Leiterin
eines Backoffices
im Bundesamt für Landwirtschaft.
Schädelis Fall ist eine Ausnahme.
Zwar sind Bäuerinnen
gefragte Arbeitskräfte
und finden nach einer Trennung
meist rasch eine Stelle,
aber nur im Billiglohnsektor.
Leider ist es halt so,
dass Papier geduldig ist.
Da muss wirklich jemand da sein,
der die Lebensläufe querliest
und sich noch etwas anderes
darunter vorstellen kann,
wenn das letzte Arbeitszeugnis
17 Jahre her ist.
Ja, und Referenzen -
was will man da angeben?
Vom Nachbarbauern, der findet:
"Sie hat mich morgens
immer freundlich gegrüsst."
Ja, es ist schon ...
Es sind andere Umstände als wenn man
einfach im Arbeitsprozess steht
und sich weiter bewirbt.
Ihre Arbeit damals auf dem Hof,
mit Familie und allem Drum und Dran,
gilt offiziell
als "nicht erwerbstätig".
Finanziell wird das Sarah Schädeli
dereinst zu spüren bekommen.
Wenn ich nur den Alltag anschaue,
dann ist es gut.
Dann komme ich gut über die Runden.
Da will ich
überhaupt nichts Negatives sagen.
Aber wenn ich weiterschaue,
mit all den Lücken,
was mir
in der Pensionskasse fehlt ...
In Zukunft sieht es auch für
den Alltag nicht mehr so rosig aus.
Mit 47 Jahren füllt Sarah Schädeli
jetzt ihre Vorsorgelücken.
* Er trällert laut. *
Von einer minimalen AHV
und Ergänzungsleistungen
wird Edith Tanner
in ein paar Jahren leben müssen.
Es steht jetzt.
Ich habe den Ständer gerichtet. Ja.
Die unbezahlte Arbeit mit der
Betreuung und Pflege von Sohn Samuel
hat massive finanzielle Auswirkungen
auf ihre Rente.
Pack den Schlüssel
bitte ins Portemonnaie!
Ja.
- Wo ist es?
Wenn ich's doch sage, ist es gut so.
Super, super, super, super!
Abschied am Bahnhof Glarus.
Einmal in der Woche geht Samuel nach
Zürich in eine Möbelschreinerei.
Es gibt immer mehr Momente,
in denen sich die Wege von Mutter
und Sohn dank Assistenten trennen.
Freiheit für beide,
die sich Edith Tanner
vor Gericht hat erstreiten müssen.
Tschüss, Samuel.
- Tschau, Samuel.
Tschau.
Jetzt geht sie nach Hause.
Bis morgen.
Unterwegs im Zug wird Samuel
einen seiner Assistenten treffen.
In seinem Unabhängigkeitsgefühl
ist er
wie ein normal Pubertierender.
Er will allein gehen.
Das macht die ganze Hilfe von mir
noch schwieriger.
Es ist sinnvoll,
wenn ich mich da raushalten kann.
Er will nicht mehr mit der Mutter.
Er will wirklich auch
selbst in die Welt hinausgehen.
* Samuel lacht wild. *
Dann gehen wir jetzt rein zu Arno.
Samuel mit Assistent Lino in Zürich.
(Mann) Hoi.
- (Samuel) Hoi.
Auch Schreiner Arno
vom Handwerkskollektiv
ist ein Assistent von Samuel.
Schau mal,
was wir letztes Mal gemacht haben!
Geleimt.
- Wir haben sie reingehauen.
Was machen wir als Nächstes?
* Samuel lacht. *
Setzen wir das zusammen?
- Ja.
Aktuell hat Samuel fünf Assistenten,
bezahlt von der IV.
Den Rest der Betreuungsarbeit
übernimmt nach wie vor die Mutter -
unbezahlt.
Als Angehörige bekommt sie von der IV
keinen Assistenzlohn.
Es hat da Hebel. Da. So.
Gut.
Du kannst den langsamen Gang nehmen.
Das ist etwas schnell.
Holst du die nächste Schraube?
Mit Arno
schreinert Samuel Möbelstücke.
Du kannst sie aufstellen.
Gut.
- Schaut mal!
Yes!
- Bist du zufrieden?
* Samuel lacht. *
Diese kleine Bank wird Platz finden
in seiner eigenen Wohnung.
Setz dich mal drauf!
- Setz dich!
Stell sie da hin und setz dich mal!
Super.
* Samuel lacht wild. *
Zwei Klagen
sind vor dem Bundesgericht hängig.
Wenn die Urteile
zugunsten von Edith Tanner
und ihrem Sohn Samuel ausfallen,
kann sie ihren Gratisjob
endgültig auflösen,
und der volljährige Samuel
kann mithilfe von Assistenten
ohne sie selbstbestimmt leben.
Bis es so weit ist, wird sie kämpfen.
Wenn er genügend Hilfe hat,
genügend Stunden zugesprochen
bekommt von Krankenkasse und IV,
dass er auch ohne meine Hilfe
leben kann, ist fertig gestritten.
Und so lange
wird man streiten müssen.
Das Problem der Versorgungslücke
sei erkannt, sagt der Kanton Glarus.
Ein Betreuungs- und Pflegegesetz
sei in der Vernehmlassung.
Ein Gerichtsurteil ist schon
zu ihren Gunsten ausgefallen,
ein zweites steht aus:
Die Ärztin Natalie Urwyler
hat das Inselspital Bern
aufgrund des Gleichstellungsgesetzes
auch noch wegen Lohndiskriminierung
angeklagt. Das Verfahren ist hängig.
Das Inselspital sagt heute,
in den letzten Jahren
sei viel in die Gleichstellung
und in die Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf investiert worden.
Mutterschutz,
Gleichstellung und Vielfalt
seien wichtige Themen
der Insel-Gruppe.
Seit Kurzem hat sich im Berufsleben
von Natalie Urwyler einiges getan:
Mit der klinischen Forschung
ist es zwar für immer vorbei,
aber nach fünf Jahren arbeitet sie
erstmals wieder in der Anästhesie,
und sie wurde leitende Ärztin
am Spital Wallis.
Man kann nicht sagen,
die Frauen machen es besser.
Ich will auch nicht nur Frauen.
Ich will eine gemischte Führung,
die einen weiten Horizont hat,
in der eben alles vertreten ist.
Das wäre ein grosser Fortschritt,
der sich auch wirtschaftlich
auszahlen würde.
In ihrer neuen Führungsfunktion
will Urwyler verhindern,
dass Fälle wie der ihre passieren,
oder derjenige ihrer Kollegin
Marie Savet-Demichelis.
Frauen, die zurückgedrängt werden,
sobald sie schwanger sind
und Kinder kriegen
und sich während
dieser Zeit nicht schonen können -
auch Demichelis hat das
an einem anderen Spital erlebt.
Ich habe mich damals
um meine Schwangerschaft
und die Gesundheit meines Kindes
gekümmert.
Der Stress bei der Arbeit
war so gross,
dass ich Komplikationen bekam.
Ich habe entschieden,
mich nicht zu wehren,
habe die Karriere beendet
und einen anderen Job angenommen.
Ich glaube,
es braucht mutige Frauen,
die machen, was Natalie gemacht hat.
Und es braucht die Unterstützung
der Männer, der Väter.
Um Gleichstellung
im Alltag durchzusetzen
braucht es nebst
einer Verfassungsgrundlage
auch den Druck der Betroffenen -
von Frauen und von Männern.
Politisch stehe sie nicht links,
sagt Ärztin Urwyler.
Doch sie,
die immer gegen eine Frauenquote war,
hat nach all den Jahren Erfahrung
in dieser Hinsicht
ihre Meinung geändert.
Heute sage ich ganz klar:
"Ich bin für die Quote."
Man könnte das z.B.
zeitlich limitieren,
bis wir ca. 30-50 % Frauen
in Führungsfunktionen haben,
dann können wir
sie wieder abschaffen.
Aber wir müssen mal anfangen,
zu korrigieren,
damit eben nicht
die grauen Eminenzen,
die schon zwei, drei Mal geheiratet
haben und immer Frauen hatten,
die alles für sie machten,
über unsere Karrieren
und Lebensmodelle entscheiden.
Ich glaube, das können wir
nur mit Quoten überwinden.
Wir haben 37 Jahre Gleichstellungs-
artikel und sind noch nirgends.
Ich glaube,
jetzt braucht es Sanktionen.
Hochbeet statt Bauerngarten.
Das Leben der ehemaligen Bäuerin
Sarah Schädeli
hat sich stark verändert.
Neben der Arbeit
hat sie ein Fernstudium
in Betriebswirtschaft
und Wirtschaftspsychologie gemacht
und vor Kurzem erfolgreich bestanden.
Sarah Schädeli wohnt mittlerweile
mit ihrer Partnerin Jasmin zusammen.
Auch Schädeli
steht politisch nicht links,
doch seit sie als Bäuerin erlebt hat,
wie Frauen sogar rechtlich
noch immer abserviert werden,
treibt sie die Frauenfrage um.
Mein Wunsch für die Frauen wäre,
dass Männer Kinder kriegen könnten.
Dann wären viele Probleme gelöst.
Das ist
eine biologische Schwierigkeit.
Aber letztendlich ist das der
Auslöser, darum geht es eigentlich.
Wer bleibt zu Hause?
Und die Wirtschaft sagt dann:
"Wenn du zu Hause geblieben bist,
kannst du nicht mehr kommen."
Auch dort wünsche ich den Frauen,
dass sie mutig sind,
sich hinstellen und merken,
was sie wollen,
was für sie stimmt und was nicht.
Und halt auch mal
unkonventionelle Wege einschlagen.